thousands of people in balata refugee
camp bid for wealth to three
Palestinians killed by Israeli forces
during a major military operation
it was a difficult night for many
residents recount their experiences to
researchers and rights organizations but
they tell us the world isn't paying
attention
has four children and is expecting a
fifth in June now she's homeless she
shows us what's left of her family's
house
we couldn't save our belongings our
clothes or anything my girls are crying
about their books school uniforms and
school bags we lost everything
she grabbed her children and ran as soon
as she could
we had no clue they would bomb the house
we had no warning nothing they planted
explosives and detonated them the doors
flew off the hinges the windows
shattered and the walls collapsed
others have similar stories people here
tell us dozens of houses have been
damaged this is the largest refugee camp
in the occupied West Bank it is
overcrowded so buildings are very close
to one another to reach the targeted
house Israeli soldiers destroy other
homes this time the Israeli Army says it
was targeting an explosives lab
although they destroyed it Witnesses say
Israeli forces failed to arrest the two
suspects the Army says the three
Palestinians were killed when Israeli
forces responded to gunfire
residents dispute this saying at least
one of the victims was unarmed
this surveillance footage shows 32 year
old Ahmad zaytoon was just leaving his
house when he was shot and killed the
Israel occupation doesn't differentiate
between a civilian and an armed man
Palestinians lives don't matter to them
the video shows how he ran away without
posing a threat
for those who lost their homes and loved
ones however the grieving has just begun
Ibrahim al-jazeera balata refugee camp
the occupied West Bank